hi reject nation Greg here so um I just
got back from movie fights on screen
junkies thank you to all who watched as
about an hour over an hour traffic
pouring rain you guys might hear it
outside and like 20 minutes before I got
back my girlfriend messaged me telling
me that daredevil was cancelled now Luke
Cage and I are fists like I mean that
makes some sense
mm kind of my iron fist more than Luke
Cage and but daredevil and I wanna make
this clear because we did a daredevil
spoiler review Andrew Gordon and I and
evidently got a lot of hate even though
I say several times that I actually
really like the season so I'm gonna
clarify this stuff front I admittedly I
could have probably lean more into my
positives the things I really liked
about it instead of really trying to
explain my criticism so I could see why
some people thought I just hated it well
that's not the case I actually really
liked season 3 of daredevil I might not
have loved it to the caliber everyone
else did but I really liked it but it
for it to be canceled though just like
iron fist and Luke Cage that was that
was a bummer but it wasn't like I need
to hop on this and talk about it I'm
like I'll just wait to talk about a
little bit later this one though
daredevil I I that I love that it's one
of them people usually asked me what
like you know what are your favorite
shows I often say friends Breaking Bad
and tear devil and True Blood or usually
the shows I list no I was I'm literally
coming from a movie fights and I was
wearing my defender shirt on the panel
today so they they they released some
statement I don't have time to edit I'm
really hungry I bought some flame
broiler so I'm sorry I don't I'm not
doing jump cuts and all that and inserts
and whatever but I saw
the article here however reporter the
Netflix statement is marbles daredevil
will not return for a fourth season on
Netflix we are tremendously proud of the
show's last and final season although
it's painful for the fans we feel it's
best to close this chapter on a high
note
we're thankful to our partners at Marvel
showrunner Erik Olson the show's writers
cellar crew and incredible cast
including Charlie Cox as daredevil
himself and we're grateful to the fans
who supported the show over the years
while the series on Netflix has ended
the three existing seasons will remain
on the service for years to come while
the daredevil character will live on in
future projects from Marvel I feel like
there's so much [ __ ] going on behind the
scenes of these Marvel shows on Netflix
because Disney has their streaming
service and I don't think these Netflix
Marvel shows would work on a Disney
streaming service but this has to be
something else going on because people
were really talking about daredevil I
know not a lot of people were really
talking about iron fist
not a whole lot of like iron fist and
Luke Cage kind of you know came and gone
and as and Jessica Jones did kind of -
but daredevil that was something a lot
of people were definitely talking about
and the fight scenes and everything
about daredevil is there there's so much
there's so much to latch onto that's so
beautiful about that show that it bums
me out that means that the fun the
ironic part about it is about as gem cus
as I fumble a lot the ironic part about
it is you know how when Luke Cage ended
an iron fist ended they they ended in a
way where like there was so much story
left to tell and while daredevil ended
on a note that had its cliffhangers and
some stuff to tease and you know not
everything is fully wrapped up
fortunately in a weird way you could
have kind of ended it with season 3 not
because it's bad or they you should
cancel it it's just like the way it all
comes full circle with Wilson Fisk by
the end and all the storylines that
unfold the way it all wraps up it you
know we were like well at least it got
canceled at a moment where
it can still feel like an ending yes
there's some cliffhangers and some stuff
that's not complete but for the most
part for daredevil himself I can see how
this could be the end to his journey and
they're talking about you know there was
some statement that my lady was reading
to me about how daredevil is going to
continue on in Marvel and other mediums
and the way I heard it was like okay
that kameena kid they're gonna go into
the movies they're gonna get any
Stratego my code is streaming service or
that could just mean daredevil will
continue to live on in the comics and
shows like cartoons or whatever but I
just want to say I'm super bummed about
this like I can't like movie fights was
super fun today and I hope you guys
watch it yeah but on what I heard that
news I was like I am weird Lee like
really affected and by this I the the
Matt Murdock character the Charlie Cox
portrayal just means so much to me I
mean think about it you spend I don't
know like close to 40 hours with the guy
hey you feel a bond and and and I I'm
really bummed about it I feel like
darrell has been a major inspiration in
my life in terms of like you know
storytelling stuff that I work on on the
side as hobbies so yeah I mean I hope if
any one of the Marvel defenders
characters could ever go into the movies
it's definitely daredevil and Wilson
Fisk so I'm hoping that if they're not
gonna come back for the show's their
performances are movie caliber acting
there and not to say that like you know
TV shows a downgrade it's just sometimes
you know they you know I'm getting out
with her with movies I don't know how I
did good on movie fights today I'm fine
I'm a little bit fried at the moment
their performances would be so awesome
to watch on the big screen that I really
hope the show does carry on and I just
want to say I'm bummed about it and I
don't know what do you guys think is
really going on I have no why
has to be something more happening
because I don't think it's a lack of
viewership and again there was a 14
minute one take so they probably threw
down a [ __ ] ton of money to make that
[ __ ] compute they're not seeing enough
profit for it sign up in the Commons
guys